le week-end dernier votre camarade
marina mills s'est suicidé baraka ce
sera filmé avec sa webcam
ne regardez pas cette vidéo voyez le bon
côté avec l'enterrement ils vont pouvoir
annuler les cours comment tu veux qu'ils
aient un enterrement ciara corps tu l'a
posté non non moi je te jure je peux pas
supprimer cette vidéo je peux même pas
supprimer mon compte est revenu dans ma
liste d'amis
ça c'est du code normal pas celui là et
c'est quoi
j'en sais rien parce qu'elle a cette
fille
non
c'est qui cette file c'est pas un
suicide
c'est au rituel est forcément quelque
chose ici quelque chose qui pourrait
nous aider
ce qu une fille de ma classe